live local now thanks for joining us
here at noon i'm heather mills and we
begin with new details surrounding a
motorcycle gang shootout it happened in
may between two rival biker gangs and
today we're finally hearing those 911
calls from that day police say six
people were hit by bullets on u.s 95.
take a listen
those angels just shot at vagos there's
two downs we're behind them we slowed
down because the minute i saw vagos and
then i saw a hell of angels they were
waiting for him on
exit they knew something they were
messing with him and then shot got fired
the call continues with the caller
saying that she doesn't feel safe to get
out and check on the victims she also
said that the other hells angels members
continued up the highway and another
person overheard on the call said they
were hesitant to download dash cam
footage of fear of retaliation
the leader of hells angels las vegas
chapter was arrested along with two
others their trial scheduled for
september